muốn dưỡng tán body
nhưng mà ngại trọng 2 BA lớp hay là loại kem khác nhau
nào là dưỡng nào là chống nắng dễ dẫn đến bết rít
bít tắc viêm nang lông
thì mọi người có thể cân nhắc 2 em body serum
mới nhất này của nhà mizumi nha
đều là kem chống nắng vật lý Lai với hóa học
sử dụng một cái hệ màn lọc y Chang nhau
chỉ số chống nắng được hãng claim
cũng không có chênh lệch đáng kể nhưng mà đều thuộc mức Cao
và đều cũng được claim
là có khả năng bảo vệ da khỏi bụi mịn và môi trường
nhờ vào một cái lớp màng chống ô nhiễm
Cho nên Trinh
thấy mọi người chọn loại nào á thì cũng yên tâm xài
chỉ cần là bôi đúng cách
thôi thì nó sẽ hạn chế được cái tình trạng da thâm sạm nám
tàn nhang hay là bít tắc viêm nang lông
còn về chất thì cũng tương tự
lỏng nhẹ
thấm nhanh ráo không lộ vân kem Cho dù là có bôi một lượng
nhiều
công nhận mizumi
xưa giờ làm chất kem body luôn đỉnh trong lòng mình
cả 2 á thì gần như không nâng tông đâu
riêng có cái em màu cam
Gluta này á thì nó sẽ nâng kiểu nhỉnh hơn cái em màu tím
PR một chút thôi trên tầm khoảng cỡ không phết 2
5 Cho đến không phết năm tông
à nước á thì có chảy về trắng nha
nhưng mà sau đó mọi người chỉ cần để Cho nước rá một xíu
sau đó là mình mát xa
thì kem nó lại ăn tệp vào da
và so với UV kem lúc này á
thì cái màng chống nắng nó cũng không có trôi đi nhiều bô
2 em này đi tập pilates
đổ mồ hôi á
thì thấy là nó không có bị dính Ra quần áo hay là thảm tập
Cho nên là mình thấy cái khả năng bám của nó rất là tốt
cuối ngày về khi mà dùng bông tẩy
trang á chỉ tính riêng Cho 2 cái phần mặt
nước của 2 cánh Tay thôi
á thì
Trinh đã phải xài
tới BA miếng bông tẩy trang mà nó còn chưa có sạch hẳn nữa
nên là bạn nào xài thì cuối ngày nhớ về tắm Cho kỹ nha
Cho nên Trinh thấy xài 2 em này hàng ngày đều rất là ô kê
từ da dầu Cho đến da khô
mà nó còn tiện lợi nữa vừa dưỡng da vừa chống nắng luôn
mà mùi thơm cũng nhẹ nhàng
còn về thành phần á thì cả 2 đều chứa vitamin C
vitamin E chống oxy hóa Niacinamide
silica để mà kiểm soát hút bớt dầu thừa bề mặt
chỉ có khác á là bạn nào mà muốn
tăng thêm cái hiệu quả dưỡng sáng bằng glutathione á
thì mọi người xài cái dòng
màu cam
còn AI da khô cần thêm độ ẩm á thì xài cái dòng màu tím
tại vì nó có thêm hyaluronic acid
nên chị lưu ý khi dùng mấy em này á thì mọi người có thể hạn
chế mặc quần áo trắng
hoặc là bôi né Ra những cái vùng da
mặc quần áo quá là bó sát á
tại vì trong này thì nó vẫn chứa cái màng chống nắng
avobenzone có thể gây vàng áo nha